Hello, everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Outlast 2.
Now we've been hiding under this little bed here, but I'm sick and tired of being chased by these assholes
who have nothing better to do but chase little old me as I'm just trying to find MY WIFE!
So I'm gonna get outta here.
I'm gonna finally get down to business and see if there's anyone beyond that door.
He-NOPE so I'm gonna press on!
(ANOTHER false bam) HWA-BOOSHKI!!!
Okay, never mind, it's a pull door instead of a push door...
But boy-howdy, I am...
I'm running out of steam here because I have been stabbed-
*Stumbing on words* I thought I heard something.
I have been STABBED repeatedly, endlessly
by every single inhabitant of this ENTIRE village and I know for a FACT...
I know for a fact they gotta be running out of people here, because this!
They keep killing everybody!
Why are you dead???
They couldn't ALL have been Heretics!
They just couldn't've...
Right?
Oh God!
Ohhhh noooo!
"Don't be afraid, you're going to heaven."
I have a funny feeling like that's not entirely true!
And also Why???
Why are you dead?
OH HI!
Yeah, what the fuck was that?
Yeah, I'm pretty sure that's absolutely true!
Ohhh 100% true.
Hello!
Hi!
Oh God they don't have any school children left!
Oh God...
Did they just kill all the kids "just in case" one of them MAY or MAY NOT have been the anti-christ?
Yeesh-aroni.
Okay, but continuing upwards...
I guess- Oh God! *Spookiplier returns*
Helloooo
Hi...
*Reading the paper*
I DON'T KNOW!!!
If you're constantly surrounded by enemies, you're just gonna be paranoid in your entire life!
(Words to live by, Mark)
Angels are gonna be stabbing wildly in the darkness- WEE OWW again I broke my ankles, okay...
*Sigh*
*Spooked
It's like the tree from 300,
Okay hi...
GOOD QUESTION I ASKED MYSELF!
Oh okay.
Wait...
So the first time in a game I look at a fence and I'm like- Oh fuck hi!
Hello again!
Nah.
Nah, I'm not gonna have none of that.
I'm gonna find something to stand on and I'm gonna be right over there. Maybe I could push this do-dadder?
Hello!
*Reading paper (x2)*
Oh, this was a KID it writing!
*Disgust*
Oh man!
*Spooked!*
Who did that?!
Oh hi!
Hello, how are you doing?
I'm about to hop this fence, so why don't you, uhh...
Carry on over there
Go fuck yourself
And when I hop over this damn fence don't be WAITING FOR ME!
They say she's gonna "pray with me" but uhh...
I think her definition of prayer isn't the same as mine.
Hello?
Well you're not there anymore, where'd you go?
Hi how you doin'?
Uh huh.
Ugh, so...
Eugh
Why do you need to carry a wife- *Giggles over his mistake* A wife? Why do you need to carry knife wherever you go?
Alright, what am I looking for here?
Oh boy more...
Hi, okay, more of this.
Ohh
*Reading paper (x3)
Oh fuck...
I can't read this like this any more!
"and upon those children, until your line is a nation.
For from your nation, your enemy shall emerge."
Okay so what was even the point then!?
If you're just gonna make children from you... Eugh- children
Then why even bother if the enemy is gonna come out of that?!
Who the frick is the enemy?!
Okay?!
Papa Knoth, you wanna "doth" me that knowledge there?! Alright fine.
*Disgruntled*
Alright, well
We know that hammer lady is coming down... Somewhere around here?
She's about to "discipline me" REAL good.
Eugh
So there's gotta be...
Gotta be some- *SPOOFED*
Nooo not scary!
(You sure about that?)
I don't think so, not scary at all.
(Are you SURE about that??)
It's awful bright in here...
Hello, bandage, do I need you?
WHAWASTHAT???
*SUPER SPOOKIPLIER*
I heard...
Oh!
Hi!
Hello, why, Why, Why, WHYY?!
I don't like your song!
I'm just gonna be open and honest, I-I-I REALLY don't like your song.
Ooooookay, bye.
I'm gonna go...
Nope, that's not a door, apparently!
YeeeeeEEEEESH!
I don't like this place...
'Kay, what do we got here?
Oh good more SCRIPTURE!
*Reading Paper (x4)
Oh shit!
*Continues reading paper (x4)*
Okaaay S.I.D. and ALL these other names!
Eugh
Alrighty then...
Oh, man.
Where am I even going?!
I mean the whole town is out looking for ME right now!
Because their digging under every outhouse for me to appear- There's a gap I can go in here...
Slip-slide!
(It worked this time!)
Sling slonk...
Okay...
So there's gotta be- EUgh!
There's gotta be reasons.
*SPOOKED ONCE AGAIN!
WOOOOO ALRIGHT THEN!
WOW okie dokie!
Okie dokie artichokee!
You need not do THAAT!
Oh hi! Oh fuck!
Ohhhh I am out of RUN JUICE!
Hide!
BUT THERE'S NO LID ON THIS ONE!
This one is gonna work LESS effectively!
Okay...
I think I'm okay?
I think I'm alright.
*IMMEDIATE REGRET*
Oh my God!
OhmyGodohmyGod RUNRUNRUN!
OHHHH my God, oh my God, oh my God, I don't know where I am!
*Ambulence impression*
Put my camera up!
Get my light on!
I don't know where I'm going!
Was this a dead end or did she chop open a way?
Ohhhh no! (x6)
Is she over there?
Oh hi!
Okay, she's not happy about me.
Oooh dodged me!
Dodge me, dodge you!
*SPOOKS*
Oooh get speed up!
Oooh slip slide!
Okay, I don't know where I'm going or I don't know why!
But she is being a big old grumpy-puss!
And I need to get the frig away from her!
So...
She's just bashing open things, so maybe there's a place thatI can get her...
To bash open?
And I'll be okay...
*IMMEDIATE REGRET ONCE AGAIN
Again with this shit!
I don't know where I'm supposed to go!
Woah, boy, she's mad!
Ohhh she's mad, definitely not there!
Not there, not there *SCREAMS IN FEAR!*
*Random noises
Okay...
So I gotta push this cart, see...
Up to that fence, see?
Okay!
Interact with this...
SHE doesn't know where I am!
Mmm!
MMM!
I don't like this!
I don't like this!!!
Oh boy!
Ohhhh bad bad bad
Bad bad bad
Gogogogogogogogogogogogo!
Oh my God!
OHMYGODOHMYGODOHMYGODOHMYGODOHMYGOD
Ah fuck!
Mmmmmm
Oh that's...
That's a good welcoming- Oh God!
I thought she was staring at me.
(What was that about being paranoid earlier, Mark?)
Okay, am I okay???
Am I okay???
I think I'm okay!
*Exasperated*
Alright, fucking st-
Don't do that...
Oh I'm outside of the church!
Okay...
Is that The Temple of Knoth or is that the Temple of HereTICKS??!!
Cos I don't think either is gonna be a warm welcome for me but let's go...
Oh frick a dick!
Alright, knock knock knock!
Or should I say "Knoth, Knoth, Knoooth?"
Did I come back here?
Is this where I was originally?
*Reading Paper (x5)
Okaaaay?
Who's Laird?
Hello?
Ahh, that looks fun.
So who's moaning?
Are you moaning?
Oh you're moaning...
OKAY
Okay, yeah, yeah, this doesn't look like a trap at all.
Can hide in those...
No, not Mary.
Nooo, oh "Judas"
I don't know if I want to...
But what about???
But I don't wanna do that!
How-I-I don't even know if that's an option to do !
Why does he have a throne!?
*Mumbling and stuttering*
I have no idea!
I have NO idea what to do.
Oh no...
Okay, well I can't go in there, I guess we're gonna just have to do this uhh...
The hard way.
Easy way...
STOP MOANING!
It interrupts my thinking process!
Okay, I guess there's nothing to do...
Is there?
Uh oh
Well I guess I made my choice!
Oh boy...
Woman: It's ME, Jessiah! Please, tell them I don't know-
Oh no...
Wait!
*Realization*
That was the girl!
On the bed!
"Paradise" "Okay"
Ohhhhhhhhhhh!
Don't DO that!
What do I just have to WATCH this?!
Whaaa?
That's not rest!
Well THIS didn't go well at ALLL!
Well!
There goes more people dying while I get little tidbits of information, SO glad that I was a part of this.
Documented the whole thing on my camcorder!
Yeah, lemme just sit here and take this in.
Just cos I REALLY wanna remember this one.
And how I dicked these people over.
Oh man, I am sorrryyy
Oh boy...
Alright.
No, I guess I WOULDN'T go the way that Papa Knoth went, I guess I'll just go the backway out of the mines where- *More immediate regret*
*Scared Markimoo noises* Skedaddle!
Time to skedaddle!
Time to skediddily-diddly-daddle!
Oh boyyy they seem to be AFTER me!
Or I guess I'll go this way, straight down the Way!
This way?
Through here?
Yes, through here.
*Confuzzled Mark noises*
Just Interact with it!
Yes, NOW would be the time to hurry!
Sssssibidy boop!
That's enough, that's enough, that's enough and close it, I CAN'T CLOSE IT!
OHMYGOD!
Didn't realize they were that close!
Woah nilly!
BAM! *gentle push*
Okay, JUST A VERY GENTLE BAMAGE!
PLEASE, I'm begging you to Bam!
Just once!
Once in your goddamn life, can you just bam?!
Made it, nailed it, okay up we go!
*Various noises from the Confuzzled Markiplier in its natural habitat
*Mumblings incomprehensible to most
Here?
I don't see a spot un- OOOOH here we go!
Got it
Alright, nailed it!
I'm so smart I found that I found that in just under 5 minutes, hi Bear.
*SUPER ZOOM*
How ya doin?
You're looking good
...frickin freak...
Okay, who do we have here?
OOH batteries, thank you!
*Spooked again*
...alright...
Uh oh...
Uh oh ohgodOhgodOhGodOHGODOHGOD
Oh oh oh oh!
Oh!
Eugh!
Okay, hello...
Hai
I'm assuming we're supposed to meet?
Hello
How ya doin?
Okay...
Oh no...
Oh you're not happy about this either.
Alright, Imma read this.
*Reading paper as Knoth (x6)
(Do you see why I'm not writing the scripture down?)
Well that's awfully egotistical of you Father Knooooth
Good ol' Papa Know-thee
So they're out here.
I think?
I think they're out here, yeah.
They are 100% out here.
Unless that's just the fire.
Which it MIGHT be!
Wait...
I'm picking up something!
Oh boy...
THIS is creepy!
Didn't actually take my time through these wodds before...
Ohhhh they're not gonna kill me!
They're NOT
Is he coming right for me?!
Where are they?!
I hear them but I don't see them!
Okay better reload...
Jeezums!
Okay they're behind me...
They're behind me now, yeah they're behind me
HOW DID I PASS RIGHT BY THEM THEN?!
Are they creeping up behind me???
Yeah
Yup, he's creeping up right behind me!
Oh my God he's right behind me!
OH MY GOD he is RIGHT behind me!
I can't see him though!
OhmygodOHMYGODOHmygod!
Uh oh!
*Markiplier giving out his Santa Claus audition tape
Ohhhhhhhhh
Skedaddle skedaddle!
Okay, crouch EEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEE
OHMYGOD! (x2)
*Sigh*
He was RIGHT on top of me!
Ohhhh Buddy Boo!
(Betty Boop's half brother?)
Buddy Boo screw you-
Oh my God he's right there!
(Betty won't be too happy with you for that, Mark.)
Oh Jeezums
Okay
I'm close!
I'm close to "salvation!"
Okay, I don't see where to go.
There's a door over there!
I think that's my ticket to ride, but I'm just gonna scout the area
Yeah, that's it!
Okay, here we go!
*Humming*
Yeah, it's open!
C'mon c'mon!
*Grrrr!*
Close that door, close it!
Okay!
For the first time in forever, they did not notice me!
They actually didn't notice me, which is damn good!
Far cry better than everything I've been doing thus far.
Why do I wanna- Ohhh that's why- Eugh...
Alright (x3)
I'll stop your wheel!
I'll stop your wheel ya Rouge!
(Who here liked Rouge One?)
I don't know if it's a good idea to stop the wheel, but Imma do it nevertheless- Ooh a CrankyCrank!
(Where is Ethan when you need him?)
This is the Crankiest Crew I've ever seen!
Okay, but I can hide in there...
There's a way to put this crank in somewhere...
A free battery there...
Ooh are they coming for me?
No...
I locked the door so I should be okay.
(Has that REALLY ever stopped the before though?)
There's gotta be a way to put Ethan in there...
I just don't know where.
So it's not here...
Oh, through here?
Hello?
Okay is anybody around?
Like who'd've thunk-
*SPOOKS*
Okay who'd'a thunk'd it it would pay to be cautious?
I certainly did GNAT!
Okay, so we gotta go up here?
FUCKING HELL who did that?
Did they just bash through the door that I locked?
Probably...
Probably, I'm gonna go with a big solid PROBABLY on that one
Here we go!
Okay
So we just gotta put this in here and crank away?
I think?
I'm tapping so repeatedly!
Okay, that's gonna stop the wheel because it's a water wheel but they did probably...
Break through that...
Oh!
He's cumming!
Oh God, he's coming up here!
Okay, so what do I do about that- Oh he's coming up here
So what I'll do is I'll drop down...
When he comes up, *I* will drop down right here...
Yeah, he didn't no-
MREH!
MAMAMAMAMAMAMAMAMA
Good thing he didn't actually TURN ON that flashlight (dumbass)
He ran out of batteries a long time ago!
Ohmygod, is that another one?
So which way ya goin' buddy?
WOOOOHOOHOOHOO HAI
There's someone in there definitely.
Someone with an actual WORKING flashlight.
Oh boy, he's coming out here
Which spells bad news for me but so long as I stay hidden
Depending on which way he goes, are you gonna go left or are you gonna go right?
Ooh you're going left
Why are you there?
WHY ARE YOU THERE?
Gonna go for it!
Eeeeeeeeeeuuuuuu
But I'm gonna go super slowly!
And then I'm gonna slip by oh so selectively over heeere!
*So many grunts and groans
Fuck where am I going now?
Uh ohhhh that's not good
Oh they know me!
I've been found out!
*EPIC PIG SQUEAL
I don't know where to go! (x4)
Reload, DON'T STOP!!!
JUST GOOOO
EeEeEeEeeEeEeeEeEeEeEeEeEeEeEe
I don't know why I did that (x2)
I don't know why I came back!!!
Why did I go there?
Oh boy I need a barrel to hide in (x2)
Ohhhhhhhh I have no time!
Oh boy! (x5)
*EPIC HEAVY METAL SCREAM*
OH COME ON!
So for some reason they didn't slash at me so I guess that's good
Oh boy, oh boy, oh boy, going back under!
So there's gotta be someway around here!
To get me out of here!
But where is it, what is it, where is it, what is it, WHERE is it and WHAT is it?
Why can't I see it why can't I find it?
Use your eyes!
Use your eyes, use your eyes, look look, oh it's RIGHT HERE?! *GROAN*
Oh Goddamn it!
Fucking stop...
Bad Guy: "... I wouldn't go down there for all the (???) in Zion."
Really?
Bad Guy: "... that's.. Marta's piece.. leave it."
Whose piece?
Whose piece is this?
Who's PEACE is this?
Oh no...
Oh nooo...
Oh that ain't good.
Methinks I may have stumbled into a "fate-worse-than-death" scenario here.
BUT OKAY
I'm a big brave boy who's gonna go in here and Ohhhh boy...
(You were saying?)
Allllright, that's padlocked...
That's dead
Greaaat
Maybe Marta...
Oof
Oh, great, yeah, slide right in there.
Yeah, don't even hesitate.
This place looks "comforting"
Frick...
Huh if I could get the gate open, huh?
If I just think about this.
Hmmmm.
I gotta find a way to fix the chain.
Something somewhere, maybe more chains?
Okay alright then, whatever you say...
So I gotta find a hook
Just don't know where that's gonna be.
At least I could get another battery...
Cos eventually, I don't think I have that many batteries
Yeah, gotta find a path to the mine to find Lynn who's having a miracle baby of some sort.
They're saying that the baby is gonna be born tomorrow and that she had immense pain in her abdomen.
Maybe it actually IS the antichrist, I mean wha-wha-who-what would I know?
I don't know a lot so I wouldn't know that.
But I'll tell you, this game has got my hearsss...
Heart racing.
Oh Chapter 1!
*Reading (x7)
I know I'm not close to Papa Knoth anymore but...
Papa Knoth, man, that guy has got some windpipes on him and I just...
I ain't ready to compete with that.
Nor do I want to , frankly.
Okay, but I got that nonetheless.
And I still gotta find a hook.
I mean, it takes a lot of energy to pump that out!
I can't imagine... I can't imagine how he's staying fat!
Oh!
Oh THAT'S MARTA!
(Repeating over and over)
Okay
Alright then
THAT'S Marta!
Ahhhhh okay
Which way are you going, Marta?
Now that I know your NAME Hammer-Lady!
Yeah, go that way you stupid!
Go THAT way, you dumb!
So I just gotta be-
Okay, I don't think she sees me
Maybe she knows when someone is watching her!
Yeah, sure, like a pig.
Why are you HOME now?
What did you take a break from hunting me?
Just so happen to come home?
Is that what it is?
I see what it is...
Okay, I think I need to go that way
Alright, but I don't wanna just constantly be running
It IS Holy ground.
WHAT DID I DO???
WHAT DID I DO?!?!
WHAT DID- OH GODDAMN IT, NO!
NO!
Owwwwwiiiiiieeeee
Okay, alright, that was unnecessary!
Oh, I don't know where I'm going...
Oh, I'm not going anywhere am I?
Ahhhh fuck, well...
*EPIC HEAVY METAL GUTTERAL \m/
Well, what can you do, she's gonna kill me dead!
Hard to get by her, she is just so...
Alright, you know what, I'm just gonna-
Hey! Hey! Hey Marta! HEEEEY MARTA!
HEEEEY Marta...
Hey Marta, how's it going?
Okay
Alright, I'm gonna loop around cos I think there's a path to LOOP.
By which to loop
AHH THIS IS NOT A LOOPING PATH!
AHH FRICK!
Owwwww okay, alright then...
Owie, oh GODDAMNIT!
AHHHH I'M A BAG OF DICKS!
I'm a bag of dicks (x2)
I'm a bag of dicks (x3)
This is not...
Excavating my crotch again.
Idk if death is any better but
Death is, Death as, unto Death
Is she gonna get me in the grass?
*DAS SPOOK*
Oh she's gonna get me in the grass, she's going, she's gonna get me in the grass...
Oh she get me in the GRASS!
Oh frick, OH THIS IS THE SAME HOLE I WENT DOWN!
NOOOOOO DON'T!
Oh apparently I'm alive, alright, okay, we'll go with that one then.
So what was the point of coming here, there is no hook here...
There is no hook. (x4)
Only death.
Please tell me you're stuck.
Are you stuck???
You're stuck, ain't ya?
Oh you're stuck, okay!
Alright!
I'm gonna rest here, I'm gonna heal oddly enough.
God, if you run for OOOOONE moment!
OOOOOOOOOONE MOMENT!
She kills you dead, Oh boy, there she goes!
She gave me my break!
She gave me my break.
My little bit of a breather.
So there's gotta be a hook.
Where the heck is there a hook?!
Okay, hooks, hooks, hooks...
HOOOOKS
HOOOOCCCCK
Not a flim flamming hook anywhere!
Not a flimble flamble hook to save my life!
There's just- OHHH HERE!!!
OHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
How often had I been there?
How often had I been cornered there and no hook!
No hook!
Not-a one hook
Oh hi, okay, you're dead, okay, Marta got you!!!
You didn't believe hard enough...
Okay...
Did I get behind Marta, cos I don't think I did!
Pretty sure uhh...
Pretty sure these COWS were non-believers too!
"Agents of the Enemy!"
If you ask me what's correct...
100% that, Ohhhhhh
Hai...
Ugggh
Alright then...
Documented THAT I gotta walk through it now!
GREAAAT!
That's...
That's not a time to make JOKES buddy!
Your wife is about to explode with the anti-christ so I don't think it's time for that bullshit, here.
(Now, that should've been in the cow room)
Okay, is there a hook?
Is there a goddamn hook in this goddamn place so I can get the goddamn outta here
and then do something better with my life than Investigative Journalism in places of death and destruction!!!
Eugh, what does she provide meat for the rest of the population here?
Cos I don't think they're very HAPPY with their customer service.
I think they've got a few complaints to make to the management here
Alright, ooh hello.
Alright, let's do THIS!
Why not?
Oh!
Oh Imgonnageta HOOOOK!
Oh good!
Uh oh, well THAT doesn't sound good.
Okay, well I got that.
*Das Spuk!*
What do I do about that?
WHat do Ido about that???
Oh he's been closed!
Ohhhh okay!
So...
So what do I do about that?
Am I trapped in here now?
I think I gotta go in here.
Eugh...
That's a lot of blood! (x2)
*READING (x8)*
Oh!
Good!
So did...
Knoth make Marta all kinds of not cool or uhh
Oh, people tried to get out of this!
-or did umm...
Was Marta like that beforehand because that's uhh...
That's to be questioned in my mind right now.
Eugh...
But I guess we gotta try to get out of here, but I have a funny feeling this is not gonna work!
Have a funny feeling
Eugh...
Marta!
Marta?
Seems like Marta's not here.
Which is weird
I assumed I was gonna be assaulted as soon as I got out of there
But apparently that is NOT true.
Okay, where is it?
Where's the place?
Reload...
She's over there!
She's right on the other side of that...
Fence...
You're just waiting there aren't ya?
Just waiting there, ain't ya-
Oh yeah, you're WAITING for me Marta!
Ohhhh boy!
Oh you're Knoth's favorite ain't ya?
If there's gotta be...
That gap back?
Pretty close to somewhere around here...
Here we go
Ohhh boy
Well...
I've got a bit of a problem here
Wait...
Wasn't she just...
Right there?
She was!
Alright then!
Guess we're fine!
Guess everything's good in this neighborhood!
THAT'S not good in the neighborhood
That's not good at all!
OOOH That's not good!
Yeeeesh!
Yidi-YOOSHdi!
Ooooh boy!
Oh boy, attach that bad boy there.
UH OH!
(Repeating Uh-Oh!s)
Go, go, goooo, GOOO!
Oh my God!
AAGH!
NO MARTA NO!
Yeah, Marta!
Take some of THAT!
Oh how do you like having violence doth done to YOU back?
Well, maybe that's too bad cos ... You deserve it!
MARTA!
Okay!
But anyway I'm all outta time for this episode
So thank you, everybody, so much for watching, hope you enjoyed this one.
I'm gonna carry on with Outlast 2 very soon!
Just so long as I can pay attention and get through this okay...
*Outro starts up!*
I think we'll be alright, we're almost at the mines!
So thank you everybody so much for watching
And as always I will see YOU in the next video.
BYEBYE!!!
*Cheery, happy funtime music starts up*
Wow, just typing all these subs was such a journey!
Took so long to do!
But, it's all in the name of Markiplier so it was worth it.
See you next time!!!